[Musique]
c'est ouf
alors on va voir la Une de Charlie Hebdo
si vous payez juste avant je voudrais
vous montrer dans toute cette peine et
cette tristesse un miracle a eu lieu
dans les décombres d'une maison dans une
ville de Syrie durement touchée par le
séisme de lundi des secouristes ont
découvert un bébé vivant encore relié
par le cordon ombilical à sa mère
décédée regardez
elle a tout juste un jour mais j'ai déjà
une survivante elle est née ici hier en
Syrie sous un immeuble effondré de
quatre étages quand les secours la
sortent des décombres alors grande
surprise elle est vivante elle est en
maillotée en urgence dans une couverture
sa mère est morte en lui donnant
naissance nous avons trouvé les corps
des parents l'un à côté de l'autre et
nous avons trouvé le bébé encore attaché
à sa mère par son cordon ombilical
elle est la seule rescapée de la famille
ses parents ses quatre frères et soeurs
sont décédés elle pèse 3 kilos 100 et
serait né à terme elle va désormais bien
malgré les circonstances
des miracles il en a eu quelques-uns
bien heureusement avec plusieurs enfants
qui ont pu être sauvés des décombres
regardez
[Musique]
voilà alors on va voir la Une de Charlie
Hebdo suite alors je vous rappelle après
au moins 20 000 morts dans CCI et en
Syrie regardez la Une de Charlie do
séisme en Turquie même pas besoin
d'envoyer de chars
la Une a fait énormément parler voilà
sur la toile bien entendu est-ce que
c'est allé trop loin tu dis ce que tu
allais trop loin et que sa caricature
oui oui oui oui oui oui
Jean-Marie le pire de tous c'est pas
drôle c'est ça c'est pas drôle quoi
je suis désolé les mecs ça fait quand
même des années qui sont pas drôle
Charlie Hebdo moi c'est ils font pas
rire
drôle ça c'est subjectif
tu rigoles pas ça c'est pas bien sûr non
mais le plus grave surtout c'est que
c'est en plus ça ne dénonce rien et
c'est ça tombe ça sort en même temps que
toutes ces images qu'on vient de voir
ces gens qui sont en plus dans un froid
glacial il y a une dame tout je voyais
ça tout à l'heure qui attend assis sur
un tabouret dans le vin froid glacial
que peut-être on chauffe ses parents
comment peut-on faire ça en même temps
ça me vraiment mais ça me dégoûte je ne
suis plus Charlie je suis plus du tout
et ça ne dénonce rien en plus c'est ils
ont fait et puis il réitère parce que le
dernier séisme en Italie
s'il vous plaît regardez
sauce tomate pennégatiné lasagne voilà
on déni on dénonce les séismes qui
rigole de ça
c'est Charlie Hebdo c'est devenu
Pacifique c'est grave c'est pathétique
oui c'est à gerber et moi j'en ai marre
qu'on se servent de l'esprit Charlie
comme prétexte pour accepter les pires
saloperie bien sûr c'est c'est il y a
aucun respect pour les victimes c'est un
drame qui est récent et on sait très
bien que leur démarche aujourd'hui c'est
plus est-ce qu'on va faire rire
quelqu'un c'est est-ce qu'on va choquer
est-ce qu'on va blesser des gens pour
peut-être faire parler de nous et je
pense que là on a diffusé la une il y a
pas une personne dans le public qui a
trouvé ça drôle personne ne trouve ça
drôle il y a aucun ressort comique
j'aimerais bien avoir leur avis si
l'esprit Charlie c'est dire les pires
saloperies pour faire parler de d'un
journal bah non on est on n'est pas de
les esprit Charline Jean qui dit non oui
parce que je suis peut-être complètement
naïf et moi j'ai pas vu du tout le
méchanceté là-dedans j'ai vu comme à
putois un hommage rendu à la à l'Ukraine
alors c'est peut-être complètement
débile mais pour moi c'était voilà
c'était genre on sert de la Turquie pour
parler du drame en du drame en Ukraine
et j'ai pas vu un côté méchant cynique
au dessin mais peut-être que je me
trompe complètement mais il faudrait
interroger le dessinateur mais je sais
pas pour moi c'était une façon de parler
de des événements et qui lirait de
drames les gens dans la douleur je sais
pas Jean-Michel c'est aberrant ce que
vous êtes en train de dire
et il te dit ce ressenti mais alors il
faudrait avoir
connaissance de ce qui se passe
prétendument en Ukraine pour comprendre
ce dessin ce dessin moi je le prends au
premier degré alors que il y a des gens
sous les décombres mais une émotion
mondiale que la Turquie et endeuillée 20
000 morts disaient Cyril au moins 71000
blessés déjà peut-être encore des
miraculés et là on les piétine dans les
foules la liberté d'expression bien fait
pour leur gueule c'est pas besoin de ça
m'a ramené en Ukraine et cetera
vraiment
moi j'ai pas j'ai pas la référence je me
dis plutôt que moi j'ai été Charlie il y
a pas de problème mais là tu fais même
les les lecteurs de Charlie Hebdo je
sais même pas si il rigole quand il voit
ça en fait non mais
c'est pourquoi
c'est fait pourquoi ils font ça au
lendemain ils attendent même pas il y a
déjà 2000 mois à 16000 morts à 16000
morts on parle à 20000 morts c'est
toujours un géométrie variable votre
truc moi
c'est toujours on se plaint on se plaint
des des toujours des mêmes toujours des
mêmes on va aider toujours les mêmes
mais il se passe pas de trucs dans le
monde on s'en bat les couilles total là
il y a 20000 morts je vois pas moi quand
je moi je suis sur les réseaux je
regarde sur Twitter je vois pas beaucoup
d'indignation du monde entier sur 20 000
morts
en quoi en quoi tu as besoin de faire
une allusion avec des charmes de
l'Ukraine en quoi en quoi on est sur
Charlie Hebdo on voit ça normalement tu
fais pas de une tu attends deux trois
quatre jours tu attends un petit peu tu
laisses le de 20 000 morts mais en fait
on répète encore sous cacher de la
liberté d'expression de la liberté de
l'humour c'est ce que vont dire mais
collègues il y a pas de souci je
respecte mais moi pour moi c'est c'est
autre chose un dessin drôle mais je
pense pas bien sûr
si toi tu avais un proche là-dedans qui
qui part dans une catastrophe c'est le
lendemain
moi ça m'a pas fait d'être 20000 morts
arrêtez de [__] de d'être méchant
comme ça
pour moi pour moi c'est de la méchanceté
toi tu le vois tu le vois avec la
référence de l'Ukraine c'est triste qui
se passe en l'Ukraine tu compares les
deux moi je ne compare pas les deux et
pour moi c'est c'est triste de faire un
dessin moi de toute façon moi-même je
vous dis faire référence à l'Ukraine
pour moi c'est pas ces deux drames
n'a nulle pas un drame bien sûr hier on
parlait des gens qui ont la carte moi
j'en ai rien qu'on parle aussi des
médias qui ont la carte parce que fait
une vanne comme ça dans notre émission
dans une autre émission à la télé on se
fait défoncer en fait parce que c'est
Charlie Hebdo parce que c'est l'esprit
Charlie on dit rien cette vanne elle est
choquante elle fait rire personne et
elle blesse énormément de gens et j'en
ai marre qu'il y a des médias qui est la
carte comme ça qui puisse tout dire en
toute impunité bah bien sûr que si mais
alors aujourd'hui
non non mais c'est pas une question de
journaliste pas de journaliste moi c'est
la façon dont je l'ai reçu je l'ai pas
du tout reçu comme un dessin van je l'ai
reçu comme un dessin qui portait un
message qui était à la fois qui qui
évoquait deux drames en un en fait et
qui parle très de ces immeubles
complètement dévastées parler de deux
drames et c'était pas pour rire d'un ou
rire de l'autre ou mettre en
correspondance
et parce que la terre la terre d'un côté
avait tué des hommes et de l'autre côté
les chars avaient tué des hommes voilà
ce que raconte ce dessin
sur un sujet aussi grave faut que le
message soit clair évident et là déjà on
est quand même pas tous des nœuds et on
comprend pas la même chose
non mais déjà le enfin voilà c'est des
gens béton quoi oui Gilles mais c'est
grave je trouve Valérie parce que vous
tentez en fait le droit
bien sûr elle a toute son avis
on pensait comme Valérie absolument mais
en fait vous cherchez à justifier pour
moi l'indéfendable c'est ça qui me plaît
pour moi ils sont indéfendables mais
c'est ça pas sur l'Italie voilà
non mais là il y a aucune compassion
pour le drame en fait il y a plus du
tout d'émotions mais la Une de sur
l'italienne
Valérie bah écoute non elle me fait
absolument pas rire ici mais moi je je
veux que le dessin de presse puisse être
libre
jusqu'à sa mort
quand on voit ça on se demande quel est
le message et en fait je me dis le gars
qui va dessiner le matin il se lève
d'une manière tellement acide et tout il
doit il doit mettre son cerveau comme ça
pour réussir à imaginer des choses et
puis quand il brainstorm avec tous leurs
collègues ils disent ok on va faire un
truc en disant pas drôle donc on le
venait pas imaginer un gratin de
lasagnes avec des gens dedans
ensanglanté et tout enfin je trouve que
c'est nul c'est vraiment et en plus le
pire c'est que ça dessert ce qui s'est
passé par rapport à Charlie parce que
tout le monde était Charlie et là en
plus c'est nul et on peut pas relier une
catastrophe et une autre que ça c'est ce
que là c'est la terre qui tremble d'un
et de l'autre côté c'est un mec qui
s'appelle Poutine et qui envahit un
autre pays qui fait la guerre et qui
canardent des gens ce n'est pas le
coupable on peut pas revenir ces deux
trucs là
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
Jean-Mi et Valérie je ne suis pas et
pourtant je ne suis pas journaliste moi
je comprends qu'on soit choqué je trouve
je comprends qu'on trouve ça dégueulasse
je trouve ça magnifique
je suis très très contente que ça existe
je pense que c'est important que ça
exige je pense que c'est la force de la
France que ça puisse exister même si
c'est noir même si c'est gerbant même si
c'est corrosif même si c'est
irrévérencieux je pense que ça doit être
ça la France c'est-à-dire qu'il faut
pouvoir faire ce dessin dégueulasse
interdit non mais non mais là vous avez
l'air de dire qu'il faut que ce soit
interdit
enfin modérateur il faut comment comment
vous voyez le dessin il y a des
modérateurs
il a des sanglots dans la voie quand il
parle de la Turquie ici excusez-moi mais
au niveau de la ligne éditoriale on en a
pas encore parlé 20000 morts on en a pas
encore parlé on en fait sur le fait ce
soir
tout le monde parle de la Turquie comme
ça tout le monde parle de la merde c'est
pas du tout le sujet juste vraiment
vraiment
a dit un truc très très vrai il y a des
régulateurs partout les mecs je suis
désolé regardez nous à la télé il y a
des régulateurs alors les gens alors eux
ils font ce qu'ils veulent non mais
c'est n'importe quoi vraiment tu es
derrière partout
est-ce qu'on peut pas juste se dire que
c'est
nulle avec les trucs avec les trucs tu
regardes dans tous les problèmes avec
les trucs de Bobo élitiste c'est souvent
pour masquer une médiocrité un manque de
talent est-ce qu'on peut pas parce que
là Valérie tu es sympa à dire oui là
vous faites la voiture retourner c'est
ce pays qui sont dessus franchement
c'est juste pas drôle c'est juste de la
merde en fait ça est-ce que tu trouves
tous les comics tous les comics
dans la tête mais quand il y a des Faits
Divers Ici on en parle le lendemain mais
tu plaisantes on rigole pas là-dessus
on a fait des dessins non mais on peut
dire
que c'est moche
des victimes en Turquie dans le pays
là c'est quoi n'importe quoi au départ
séisme en Italie c'est en Turquie non
non mais je dis votre raisonnement sur
la Turquie elle a dit qu'on peut
l'entendre sur l'Italie
reprendre ils ont fait des dessins qui
étaient des mais il y avait quelque
chose à dénoncer c'est ça exactement la
raison Daniel c'est une catastrophe
naturelle qu'est-ce que tu veux très
bien fait il y avait quelque chose à
dénoncer vraiment vraiment
quelque chose elle a raison Daniel on a
le droit d'être dans la fête ne mélangez
pas de la guerre ne mélangez pas à une
catastrophe naturelle on sait pas bien
ça c'est un tremblement terre ne
mélangez pas ça avec un attentat
il faut réagir tout de suite
mais là on parle c'est la terre c'est
comme ça ça a été décidé comme ça 20 000
morts ça a été décidé comme ça et
peut-être même plus c'est écrit comme ça
on peut pas rigoler mais regarde pas
Michel on peut attendre on veut pas
censurer parce qu'il reste bloqué sur le
fait que c'est pas drôle si jamais
de la famille mais j'avais des proches
des copains 20000 morts et je vois ça
j'ai envie moi de m'énerver bien sûr
parce que tu crois que c'est quelque
chose qui est fait pour blesser
il y a beaucoup de gens qui réagissent
non c'est inacceptable il faut rien
lâcher là-dessus voilà on remercie pour
pour vos messages et il y a des
communautés turque aussi qui qui réagit
hein ce soir qui dit demande à Géraldine
si la France avait subi le même drame et
que l'Allemagne avait fait ce dessin
comment elle réagirait ça a l'air de la
déranger qu'on parle de la Turquie
n'importe quoi
ils étaient sous les bombes pendant des
années il y a des enfants qui sont morts
pendant des années en série jamais
personne s'est déplacé pour la série
jamais on a payé 2 euros d'essence pour
la série on en a rien à [__] des
gamins on s'en fout et me dis pas que ça
on en a pas mal je voudrais dire quelque
chose je suis rien contre la Turquie
c'est d'avoir à la fois Charlie Hebdo et
grâce à l'humanitaire on en voit plein
d'aide aussi en Turquie et pourtant les
relations diplomatique ne sont pas
excellentes avec la Turquie on va voir
ce qu'on pensait téléspectateurs ah
voilà
72,9% voilà voilà oui oui mais c'est
toujours l'émotion c'est toujours les
mecs sous le couvert du journalisme et
de la bien-pensance à un moment ils font
n'importe quoi oui non mais là où vous
trompez je pense c'est quand vous dites
il voulait pas être drôle moi je pense
qu'il croit être drôle bien sûr
et peut-être qu'il y a un humoriste qui
aurait réussi à faire je dis pas une
blague mais peut-être une remarque
pertinente un truc qui fait réfléchir là
c'est juste nul en fait tu es nul est-ce
que c'est Charlie Hebdo tout le monde
doit rigoler tout le monde doit trouver
ça mais c'est nul désolé
on rigole pas quand même